يتهم وزير الخارجية الأمريكي
والسفير في أوكرانيا
روسيا باستخدام الجوع كسلاح
حرب ، ويقولان إن روسيا تمنع
السفن من تحميل الحبوب في
موانئ أوكرانيا وفشلت في تفتيشها أثناء
مغادرتها لعبور البحر الأسود تحت البحار
الدولية.  صفقة الحبوب في هذه الأثناء ،
ينتظر الأوكرانيون الشرقيون الذين يعيشون في القرى القريبة من الخطوط الأمامية بفارغ الصبر الهجوم الأوكراني المضاد المتوقع
لإنهاء
الخوف الذي كانوا يعيشونه في ظله
منذ بداية الحرب التي يُنظر إليها على أنها واضحة
سيباستيان هنا في لندن ، نيك روبرتسون
في شرق أوكرانيا.  بدأ نيك
معك في أن التوقعات من مختلف
الحكومات الغربية لا تبدو
عالية بشكل خاص بالنسبة لهذا
الهجوم المضاد ، فإن فكرة أنه من
المحتمل أن تستمر حرب الاستنزاف هذه ،
ولن تكون هناك
نتيجة نهائية منها ، ولكن
أوكرانيا فاجأت.  مرارًا وتكرارًا
في معنوياتهم وعزمهم ، وأنت
ترى أن مكانك موجود ،
وأعتقد أن هذا ربما يكون جزءًا من
التوقعات التي تم التقليل من شأنها من قبل
القادة الغربيين حلفاء أوكرانيا
لأنه من الواضح أن الدعم الذي
يتلقونه من شعوبهم
لمواصلة  إنفاق الكثير من المال والدعم
تعتمد أوكرانيا على كيفية
تحديد تلك التوقعات.
القادة الأوكرانيون يدركون جيدًا تلك
الديناميكية المعينة عندما نتحدث معهم ،
فهم يتوخون الحذر ويتحدثون عن
كيفية إساءة فهم هذا الأمر في
الغرب بأن هذا يعد بمثابة مواجهة-  هجومية
من المحتمل أن تكون دموية للغاية ،
إنها ليست مثل لعبة حرب ليست مثل
هوليوود يقول البعض منهم لنا لذلك أعتقد أن هناك
فهمًا حقيقيًا لتلك الديناميكية ، هناك
أمل حقيقي هنا في أن يتمكنوا من اختراقها ، لقد
حققوا نجاحًا خلال  عطلة
نهاية الأسبوع أه ليست بعيدة في باكموت في
شرق أوكرانيا قادرة على قطع عدة
كيلومترات من الأرض هناك
أخبرنا ضابط متورط في ذلك أنهم
اعترضوا الاتصالات الروسية وأن
الروس فوجئوا
بأنهم فقدوا الأرض أه تقارير أخرى تقول
تلك الأرقام  عدد كبير من
الجنود الروس ومرتزقة فاغنر الذين
قُتلوا في هذا الهجوم بالذات ، لكنني
أعتقد أنه عندما تتراجع عن هذا
النوع من السرعة الفورية في خط المواجهة ،
ويمكننا الحصول على رؤى في كثير من الأحيان حول
شكلها وشعورها بالقرب من
الجبهة  خط نتراجع مسافة 12 ميلاً و 20
كيلومترًا أو نحو ذلك من
خط المواجهة ، لذا ألقِ نظرة على
حياة الناس هناك القريبين جدًا من
خط المواجهة في الواقع لأن القذائف
والصواريخ يمكن أن تصيبهم وكيف
يتقدمون في طريقهم.  حياة
جاهزة على بعد
أميال من الجبهة الشرقية لأوكرانيا ، الحياة
طبيعية نوعًا ما على الرغم من أنها ليست
خارج الحرب من يحتاج إلى الكثير من
أدوات
التمويه هذه ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، شكراً جزيلاً لك للسماح
لك بإعطائي قبعة صوفية لطيفة
لإبقائي دافئًا.  في خوف على الرغم
من أنهم يشعرون بذلك ، فنحن لا نعرف ما
يحدث بعد 30 دقيقة من الآن ، تقول ،
ناهيك عن ساعة من
القلق التي تظهر في حديقة المدينة ، إما أن
العمال يقطعون العشب لأن
قذائف المدفعية تمزق الحقول ليست بعيدة جدًا مما
يظهر الخوف يبدو أنه  لقد تم التخلي عن
تحذيرات الغارات الجوية المهجورة الآن
أصبحت صفارات الإنذار مثل هذه
الحياة هنا الذين يعيشون خلال الحرب التي
لا يستجيبون لها حتى ، لاحظ
فلينش حتى أن الحرب
موجودة في حياة الناس
خارج المدينة حتى أقرب إلى الجبهة
يقول هذا الزوجان المسنان بلا مبالاة  لقد
تم قصف منزلهم الشهر الماضي ،
حتى أنه يمزح أنه ممل عندما
لا يكون هناك إطلاق نار على حد سواء ، على الرغم من الأمل في أن
الهجوم المضاد القادم في أوكرانيا
سينهي معاناتهم
نحن نعتقد أن أوكرانيا ستدخل هناك
وتهزمهم جيدًا.
أعشابه أكثر من الحرب ،
نحن لا نفهم أي شيء عن
الهجوم المضاد ، كما يقول ، إننا نأمل فقط
لأوكرانيا للدفاع عننا
حيث ومتى يبدأ الهجوم المضاد ، قد
يكون أحد أفضل أسرار الحرب المحفوظة
حتى الآن
اللغز هو بالضبط  ما
تريده أوكرانيا يُبقي روسيا على التخمين لتمديد
خطوط الإمداد الخاصة بها يضعف معنويات القوات في
Victory Rides الأوكرانية أثناء
القيادة المفاجئة بالقرب من الخطوط الأمامية هنا ،
يمكنك سماع بعض القصف عن
بُعد ويمكنك رؤية الكثير من
الجنود حولك ولكن ما لا
تفهمه  من هو أي حشد كبير لهجوم
مضاد يقوم
المزارعون هنا بحساب
نجاح قواتهم في زرع المحاصيل في الحقول التي يريدون
حصادها بالكامل ،
ويأملون أن
يؤمن الهجوم المضاد أرضه ، لكنه يقول إنه يعرف أن
بعض الجنود هنا يعرفون كيف
سيعلم القتال بشدة أنها ستكون
معركة دامية
وأعتقد أن هذا يردد حقًا ما
سمعناه من ذلك الضابط القائد حول
أنها ليست هوليوود ، إنها معركة حقيقية
وأعتقد أن هذا يصل إلى تلك النقطة من
التوقعات التي أصبحت واقعية في
العواصم الغربية.  لن يكون الأمر
سهلاً ولكن الأوكرانيين
مصممون تمامًا على القيام بذلك